from wbur boston i'm tom ashbrook and
this is on point salman khan is one of
the most influential teachers in the
country his short 12 minute video
lectures are watched by more than a
million are watched more than a million
times a month yet khan doesn't have a
teaching degree or a classroom what he
has is a wildly popular simple online
method of teaching the basics of math
physics biology history and a dozen
other subjects he calls it the khan
academy and it is turning classroom
thinking upside down this hour on point
solomon khan online instruction and the
future of education you can join the
conversation is that you out there
watching learning from salman khan has
he become your online teacher tutor your
child's is this the education fix we've
been looking for we're at 1-800-423-8255
that's
800-423-talk and you can comment at our
website onpointradio.org or on twitter
and facebook at onpointradio later this
hour we'll talk with peter norvig who
co-teaches a free online course on
artificial intelligence at stanford
university which has already signed up
58 000 students for its delivery
this fall but first to solomon khan he
is making
big waves in the world of education with
some pretty
simple at least on the surface uh video
online he got to start making videos
about math and science did a lot of them
with a 25
headset microphone and a little setup in
a closet just churning them out here's a
video from last year where he explains
something pretty simple compared to some
of his work how to calculate the square
root of one hundred
a hundred is the same thing as ten
times ten and then you know the square
root of something times itself that's
just going to be that something this is
just equal to ten so the square root of
a hundred is ten
or another way you could write i guess
the same truth
is that ten
squared which is equal to ten
times ten
is equal to
one hundred sounds simple maybe so if
you can figure it out if it works for
you it's great these videos have been
washed at this point more than 70
million times joining me now is solomon
khan he's the 34 year old founder of the
khan academy he has three degrees from
mit in electrical engineering and
computer science and a master's in
business administration from harvard he
was working as a hedge fund analyst when
his young cousin needed help with her
math homework his tutorials for her went
up on youtube and became so popular that
he quit his job in 2009 to run the khan
academy full-time solenoid khan welcome
to onpoint
great to be here tom you're really
shaking it up out there i mean uh wired
they call you a nerdy south asian
seinfeld south asian american seinfeld
i assume the nerdy was an endearing form
absolutely the highest praise highest
praise these days nerds are exactly what
we need you've gotten so many people
tuning in to you i know you've told this
story a million times but tell us once
more what were you doing when your
cousin uh called up for some help
yeah she was actually visiting me in
boston from new orleans and uh she was
in seventh grade and i remember we were
watching the fireworks over the charles
river and she was doing all these brain
teachers that i was giving her to kill
time so i was really impressed and i i
was telling her the next day that you
know she should think about going to mit
when she applies to colleges and uh
her mom actually said well you know
thanks for saying that when nadi was
away but she said
nadi is actually having trouble with
math so uh i i chatted with nadia she
apparently had bombed a placement exam
and and she had trouble getting units
you know converting kilograms to grams
and all the rest and so uh i said hey
nadia how about i tutor you remotely so
we started setting that we started doing
that as soon as they went as soon as her
family went back to new orleans and uh
that worked out then i started tutoring
her brothers and a couple of other
cousins and family friends and then
in 2006 so that'll start in 2004 in
2006. i had a buddy and i was i was just
telling him about you know this is i'm
having a lot of fun doing this kind of
volunteer tutoring with my family but it
it i have trouble scaling now that i
have a lot of family friends that i was
tutoring after work and uh he's like why
don't you put some of your lectures on
youtube and and i said no that's for
dogs on skateboards that's not for for
real math
with it but uh i i i gave it a shot and
and you know i guess i guess the rest is
history uh history
in a way
give us a visual picture of these
lectures this is not you standing up
there in a cardigan like mr rogers in
fact we never see you wired magazine
says like the wizard of oz khan never
steps from behind the curtain it's just
you your voice and scrawling equations
on a kind of electronic whiteboard uh on
whatever it may be
yeah i know you know after that first
that first day when i was attempting to
make videos i literally looked around my
my my closet and and i had no video
camera had no real
recording equipment to speak of i did
have a a
usb headset and i did a few web searches
and there's this kind of software called
screen capture software where it just
captures what happens on your screen and
turns it into a video in your voice and
uh i thought you know that that's
probably good enough because that's what
i was doing with nadia when she's when
we did our live sessions we get on a
speaker phone and then we would use
yahoo doodle which was this little
shared notepad and and it not only did
it seem to work but but it seemed to in
some way be a little bit more intimate
than someone standing at a white board
and and kind of talking to a class and
so i i tried it out and you know in
those early days i was just like look
it's just from my cousins they're not
paying me who cares
and uh but but as soon as i did that and
i just got a lot of feedback from uh
both my cousins and and random people on
on youtube saying that they really liked
that form factor that it allowed them to
focus on the content they didn't have a
distracting phase it felt personal it
felt like we were sitting next to each
other the at the kitchen table and
staring at the same content that was
with cousin nadya in 2004 and then a few
more cousins and and relatives uh what
we're just talking six or seven years
ago give us a sense of the scale
of
students around the world who are now
interacting with these videos online
with khan academy
yeah we're now at about two million
unique students a month i mean as you've
mentioned they've been watched 70
million times and uh
uh yeah and and that that number has
grown ten for the the number of students
watching it per month has grown tenfold
in the past year so it's kind of on this
it's a
surreal growth growth trajectory and
it's not just uh the square root of 100
i was checking out uh your little mini
video lecture on taylor's polynomial
this morning i mean you you take it in
all kinds of directions and it's not
even just math anymore uh salman khan
yeah you know when i when i started this
off i was making videos roughly in kind
of the pre-algebra algebra area for
mainly for my cousins but but the one
thing that started to dawn on me is once
i had maybe 100 or 200 videos from my
cousins is you know you know that that's
a pretty good scaffold of algebra and i
said well i wonder if i could do
trigonometry so another hundred videos
later it's like hey you know that's a
pretty good scaffold you can always do
more but that kind of gets a good job
done for a lot of people that said let
me try to do calculus let me try to do
physics let me try to do chemistry let
me try do organic images
so so part of the fun of this is just
being um
seeing seeing what we can do and and the
really neat idea here and it seems
obvious now in hindsight is that uh most
of these subjects do not change in a
dramatic way from year to year and so
once you make a decent collection of uh
algebra videos they're kind of good
forever i still redo videos just to make
them nicer or to touch on a point in a
different way but for for the most part
they're kind of evergreen content you've
got two or three thousand of these mini
lectures up now these tutorials give us
the range of subjects that you're in at
this point yeah there's literally a
video on on basic addition
and the mindset there is to have so
everyone can feel like they have a
starting point on that site and
literally it the videos go incrementally
from basic edition through vector
calculus and differential equations and
uh college level chemistry biology and
physics there's a a little bit on art
history not on american history um so uh
yeah it's a pretty it's a pretty broad
set of content a lot of on finance and
economics as well now and at this point
is this just a little nice
free tutorial for people who happen to
stumble on it or are you
orchestrating something that may be
bigger something different is this just
the solomon khan's favor to the world or
is this a game changer for education
well you know we'll uh we'll see what it
can do in terms of uh being a game
changer but what we are as an
organization is much more than me now uh
i quit my job in 2009. last year we got
uh significant funding from uh the bill
melinda gates foundation and from google
and other uh private donors a million
and a half from bill gates i think
something like six million in total has
come your way now
yes yes and so we have a team of uh 14
people i would say about two thirds of
those people are focused on the software
side uh khan academy now is the videos
are there and that's probably where most
people's first experience happens uh but
what we're trying to do is turning into
a full for lack of a better word virtual
school where anyone can go there they
have the videos on demand but they also
have exercises and the exercises start
them in basic edition there's these game
mechanics around it it keeps track of
their progress gives them feedback if
they have a teacher or a parent that can
act as a coach it'll give them data and
analytics on it and so the the idea is
if you have nothing if all you have is
access to the site you can get a a
pretty solid grounding in a lot of core
concepts and if you do have access to a
teacher this has the potential to really
supercharge what happens in the
classroom and it's all free we'll talk
about how it works for individuals how
it works in the classroom solomon khan
is with us from palo alto california
founder of khan academy salman khan
we've got lots of listeners calling for
you already chanel in hampton virginia
chanel thanks for calling you're on the
air with solomon khan
hi good morning how are you great
hi mr khan
hi chanel
what's up how are you i i love you
you're such a life saver i love i love
all your lectures
i mainly go to the
organic chemistry lectures
and i'm a college student and they're
very informative you're such a lifesaver
i'm getting all the methods in such a
short number of time
uh it takes i mean your videos about
nine ten twelve minutes
and my lectures are about
an hour 45 minutes like three times a
week
so what are you doing are you skipping
your lectures and just taking salman
khan's 10-minute pop
you know you know i could i could
actually do that
i could actually do that because you
know i can understand it much much more
we usually use
uh powerpoint
just that when khan does it
he uses a lot of colors uh
he
i know it's just something that he does
and i'm just i'm it's so much easier to
grasp
and even organic chemistry itself is not
one of the easiest subjects
organic chemistry
right across the country in hampton
virginia chanel's on it with your
10 minute videos chanel thanks for
calling we're going to learn a lot more
in this hour solomon khan is with us
founder and executive director of the
khan academy listeners you can join us
are you your kids hooked on solomon khan
khan academy and what it's made is
simple online math videos and now a lot
more such a sensation
800-423-8255 is our number 800-423 talk
summon khan stand by i'm tom ashbrook
this is on point we'll be right back
i'm tom ashbrook this is onpoint and
we're talking this hour with the what
now rockstar famous video math teacher
and more
salman khan founder of khan academy and
one man online education
sensation he has kids millions of them
eating up math and physics chemistry and
learning you can join the conversation
this hour what do you think is this all
we've needed all these years a
compelling guy online with a whiteboard
explaining it again and again students
has salman khan helped you how why
what's it about
what's it about the way he does it and
what about it and parents has this been
your salvation your good free tutor for
the kids teachers what do you think
we're at
a year 800-423-8255 july 2010 at the
aspen ideas festival here was microsoft
founder bill gates suddenly talking
about golden age for online learning and
khan academy
if you're motivated to learn if you
really really really want to learn
this is a an amazing time
for everyone because if you have access
to
wikipedia if you have access to the
latest information on the web there's a
new website that i've just been using my
kids recently called khan academy khan
just one guy doing some unbelievable
15-minute tutorials there's great
college lectures out on academic
earth.org so if you're motivated now you
can go to the very best lectures there
it is bill gates talking about khan
academy spelling out your name salman
khan k-h-a-n how did you find out that
suddenly bill gates had your work on his
lips
yeah it was it was someone in the
audience uh actually our first major
donor anne doer had uh sent me a text
message while that wife of john doe huge
venture capitalists in california right
right and uh you know i got the text
messages and actually i was running a
little summer camp for for seventh
graders at the time and i had all of
these seventh graders running around i
was doing this kind of public trading uh
markets experiment with them and i got
this text saying bill gates is talking
about you in front of two thousand
people and and and i i my first reaction
is that ann just sent the text to the
wrong person
she she probably knows people who bill
gates would talk about
that wouldn't be me
uh and here you are with these lectures
what what what is it supposed to be is
it a tutor essentially that you amount
to online who supplements the teacher is
it
or for students who don't get it or is
it is it an entire learning path in and
of itself where students can just kind
of latch on to your sequential lectures
and run through all of math or you name
it if they're ready to do that how do
you picture this being
used because you're talking a mass scale
here i mean you've got two million
unique users a month now you're talking
maybe reaching tens hundreds of billions
of students around the world
you know
at least for us it's kind of an open
question what it is we're not we're not
100 sure i think to some degree all of
those use cases apply there's definitely
a lot of students like chanel who are in
a in a formal uh
education system taking a class and they
they use this as either a supplement or
maybe in you know uh maybe this is where
they're actually getting the information
from and they they're really using the
class as a way of of showing that they
know the information uh we have use
cases where it's being used with the
classroom where the teachers are
actively using the videos as as a way to
give students kind of the first pass
information and then that allows that
frees up the teacher to kind of do
higher order uh interactions with the
student um we have adult learners who
are learning calculus just for fun uh so
so it's really an open question on on on
what this can can be uh we've got all
kinds of response here on facebook danny
lee says my 3.92 would not be possible
without khan marcy says the way teaching
ought to be thanks to someone khan my
sixth grade son loves
math now you've got you've uh got a
school system los altos in california
who's taken this on in some of their uh
grade years in a pretty big way and from
what i'm reading solomon it it has ended
up kind of flipping the normal classroom
routine in a lot of ways that students
would get their lecture on the subject
from you at home and then in the
classroom essentially be doing their
homework with the teacher there to help
them out is that right
to some degree we kind of view that
actually as a first order thing that can
happen and that that was happening
independently of us probably two or
three years into me making the video i
started getting letters from teachers
saying that they were doing exactly that
they're saying hey why do i have to give
the lecture you already have that
lecture and the students can pause and
repeat and watch at their own pace and
move ahead or back up and review things
what we're doing with los altos i would
say is even a step deeper where they're
using the videos and they're using our
software platform where every student in
these classrooms is working at their own
pace and uh whether they're at home or
in the classroom they might at that
moment watch a video or they might do
exercises and uh and it's it's all
self-directed and what happens when they
go into the classroom is that the
teacher gets a dashboard seeing where
every student is and it highlights the
students who look like they they they
really need need help and so the teacher
every moment of a teacher's time instead
of lecturing or grading papers or any of
the rest is spent doing direct
one-on-one interactions or small group
interactions with with their with
students or even better getting students
to to help each other it's it's pretty
amazing when you look at the classrooms
there's these super interactive
experiences where these kids are walking
around helping each other teaching each
other and
the teacher is actually you know sitting
next to students
pretty much the entire class time and uh
in many ways going at their own pace
whether that means catching up to where
they ought to be grade level or in some
cases going far far beyond i'm curious
how
classrooms and teachers handle that
someone can't stand by if you would in
palo alto for a minute we have a teacher
from the los altos california school
system with us courtney cadwell joins us
now from los altos uh courtney
cadwell thanks very much for being here
hi tom thanks for having me you teach
seventh grade remedial math i think
they're in los altos and junior high yes
that's the
class that we piloted uh the khan
academy with last year and you've been
teaching for 17 years today's the first
day of school there in los altos welcome
welcome back to work yes thank you how
are you using um solomon khan's videos
with your classes what's it look like
courtney
every day looks differently in my
classroom i like to try new things i
keep calling my students my guinea pigs
and i'm trying to differentiate
instruction for them and and do what's
best based on their needs and so
sometimes we'll do the videos for
homework or the practice modules for
homework sometimes we'll integrate them
into class time i'll do a lot of
stations where students maybe watch a
video or work on the online modules for
a little bit and then they'll do some
group problem solving or project-based
learning activities and then i'll have
time to sit with them look at the khan
academy data and really target my
intervention strategies and my
instruction based on the data i'm
receiving from their practice modules so
it's not just these lectures it's
exercises at this point lots and lots
and lots of problems that your students
can do and you see on this kind of
dashboard how they're doing with those
problems essentially as they do them
courtney exactly i get the data in real
time so i know exactly who's struggling
at what time with what they're
struggling i can go look in and see the
types of problems where they're missing
it how much time they're spending those
types of things so i can really go to
that child and tell him or her you know
hey let's work on this together let's
figure this out and so i instead of
guessing takes a lot of the guesswork
out for a teacher i can really go in
there and figure out who i need to meet
with what we need to talk about how i
can get them back on the right track a
lot of your students uh have not been
real keen on math historically right
they come into this with they're with
you because math was not their favorite
subject how's this working it it's been
amazing um i've just seen a great
attitude attitude adjustment in my
students they love coming to math class
now the the online modules this this um
the way they have the modules set up
it's like a kind of like a game and they
earn points and they earn badges and the
kids are very motivated to um to work
these problems i could never get them to
work this many problems on their own and
um and they want to do this and they
look forward to it and um and it's just
changed their entire impression of math
they've also started to take ownership
of their learning because as they're
moving at their own pace they can get
hints and they can watch one of sal's
videos and get a lot of help there and
in the past they've been very passive
learners just waiting for the teacher to
instruct them and tell them what to do
and now they're becoming active learners
and and taking more responsibility with
their education and really going for it
and trying new things and they know
where to go to get help now and um and
i've it's been a great change
in them as learners and you're speaking
as a pretty experienced teacher you say
they earn badges this is sort of video
game style where you get you know little
images and icons that to mark your
success as you go through these
exercises exactly and the and the badges
aren't just for getting things right
it's for perseverance and trying and not
giving up and things like that so even
you know struggling students are
continuing continually earning these
badges and they're they're motivated to
move forward and not to give up this
this helps in your classroom does it
also blow up the traditional classroom i
mean i'm reading here about some
students you know using this in fifth
grade and they're racing ahead to sort
of uh i don't know high school or
college level trigonometry what what
happens when the classroom sort of can
follow you know the threads wherever
they go here at their own speed and
they're all over the map
well i think it does blow up the
traditional classroom and i think that's
very exciting um it's it's a very active
class um the kids are going at their own
pace um the teacher you know kind of has
to have a good working knowledge of math
so you can intervene at multiple levels
at any one time you never really know
what the day is going to look like when
you're using the khan academy in your
classroom but the kids are motivated
they're moving ahead they're doing well
we're getting great feedback um from the
khan academy but also from our other
testing
situations as well so um it's a very
positive thing and i think it's it's
stretching us as educators starting to
think about how we do
math education in our classrooms what
those classrooms will look like and and
i think the khan academy is a step in
the right direction and it's a good
bridge between you know the past and the
future of education with this um online
platform there's an awful lot of online
material and digital material available
today
why this one i know they came to los
altos and so your whole school system is
involved in it but is it because it's
free not a small thing is it somehow
because of
i mean solomon khan does most of these
himself and he's got this kind of uh
forgive me solomon but it's a little bit
doofussy or it's real casual sort of
presentation it's not polished up
is it is it because it's free courtney
is it because you've got solomon just
kind of laying it out there what is it i
think it's definitely a little bit of
both free is very nice for our school
district and this financial climate um
and then having you know the access to
salman and and his uh crew over there at
the khan academy is is very helpful as
well um but it's you know it's very
simple it's very engaging his videos are
straightforward they're very
conversational um
you can sit down and learn something
just in a short period of time and
really get a good handle on it
it's the the online modules are very
engaging for the kids um there there's a
lot of stuff out there and i think in
los altos you know different teachers
use a lot of different things and and
we're really trying to create blended
learning environments in our classrooms
and khan academy is one of those tools
and it's a tool that i've really enjoyed
using this past year and look forward to
using more um and i think the other
teachers in the district will buy into
it as well but definitely the the free
part and then um and south is very good
teacher um online and so so that
definitely um uh boosts his credibility
with us uh courtney cadwell it's great
to have you with us on this first day of
school in los altos california and thank
you very much for your time and thoughts
my pleasure thank you so let's stand by
for just a second i want to get you back
in here but we've got a lot of listeners
jock in charleston south carolina you're
on the air with solomon conga
okay thanks hello um i have a only some
comments and no questions um first i i
took organic chemistry in college and
continued to have an interest in physics
particularly quantum mechanics
uh strong and weak nuclear force
electromagnetism
and other objects subjects
i read scientific american to try to
follow these topics but i do that with
difficulty and about a year ago i found
khan's lectures on
these deep dark mysterious subjects and
his lectures made everything clear to me
and he beats uh the heck out of
scientific american and that's all i had
to say uh
that's that's an endorsement right there
jock let me get one more rainer in
nashville rayner you're on the air
hi tom hi
hi um i just like to say i'm a senior in
college and i've always had an interest
in
science and math but around eighth grade
i kind of missed a couple of uh key
lessons and probably pre-calculus and so
it made it really difficult for me to
keep following along in
algebra but this past year i decided you
know i'm kind of cocky hey you know why
why am i so bad in math now it can't be
my intellect
and i uh i went on and found the uh
the khan academy and started taking the
videos but my question actually has to
do with
user interaction on the khan academy
website
um i i was wondering if uh is the
question for sal if if they plan on
developing anymore in that arena you
mean sucker for the trivial points that
you get when you sort of complete
challenges and watch videos
but i i was wondering if if they planned
on developing that more and and really
what i had in mind was sort of
challenging other users to competitions
or to math or many math competitions so
sort of community or social use of the
site uh rainer right
so
how about it
yeah yeah no that's that's on our
pipeline it's something we want to do
very seriously uh you know right now we
have two million students and they're
kind of each individually working on
their own unless they have a coach or a
teacher to work with and we think it
could be fun to to have some of these
challenges and have some a little bit of
a competitive framework in place and a
little bit of a
kind of multiplayer gaming framework and
we're just going to try to balance it so
we don't want it to turn into an overly
competitive environment but but uh no
completely agree and we think uh that
definitely speaks to something that i i
would also enjoy participating
expect to see some of that in the next
six months thanks for your call from
nashville rainer so
you're on the record here talking about
not just 2 million students but 10 or 20
or 50 or 100 million students it's free
now and you've got a lot of kind of
foundation supporting here bill gates
and the google and others does it stay
free or are you building a
gigantic business here
yeah so so uh the the simple answer is
yes it it'll stay free it's a uh you
know this was this was set up as a
not-for-profit not that not-for-profits
can't charge obviously most universities
are not for profits and they they're
very good at charging for things but uh
uh but the reason why honestly why i
wanted to make it for not for profit is
so that i or the rest of your
organization doesn't is always focused
on that mission and which is educating a
world-class education for anyone
anywhere for free and um and and so that
is core to what we're doing
we we it's possible that i mean we with
that said we need to sustain ourselves
somehow and uh so we are looking for
ways to do it i hope that foundations
continue to believe that this is
probably the most
scalable way to educate people and and
have a high social return on investment
um but at the same time there's other
possibilities you know corporations have
come up to us and said hey can we use
this for our corporate training maybe
there's a way to sustain ourselves maybe
uh um who knows that's kind of an open
question still but the core to our
mission is keeping our content that
people get khan academy.org completely
free it's obvious that you have a knack
for this a lot of people not millions
responding to it what are the
implications of that that we what do we
end up i mean courtney we didn't get to
this but she used your stuff in africa
in kenya last summer i mean we're gonna
have one math teacher in america one
math teacher in the world who happens to
be good at getting the concepts across
what are the implications of that
what i suspect is you you'll you'll have
uh a handful of of
lecturers uh who make these type of
videos it won't just be me in fact we're
already starting to talk to some other
groups about making other videos and
especially on topics that i'm not
competent to give lectures in
but what i think it does is it doesn't
it doesn't replace teachers it actually
lets them go up the valley jam you heard
courtney talk about how it's changed
what happens in the classroom she can
now intervene she's actually she's
actually using her
her the fact that she's a human in a
human way she's not doing things like
giving the same lecture every every year
or every class period and so what i hope
happens is that
what you see in classrooms is no longer
a lecture what you see in classrooms is
no longer kids sitting passively what
you start seeing in classrooms around
the world is kids trying to interact
with each other kids doing more projects
kids doing a lot of the higher order
types of things that most teachers i
think dream about and and before they
never had the time to do it or a way to
address it or or a way to cater to every
student in a meaningful way so you give
the kind of rudimentary material even
when it's the or the sort of base
lecture and they they take it from there
sama khan it is fascinating stan stand
by if you would in palo alto we've got
to take a short break here we're talking
with the now rock star famous video math
teacher and more solomon khan of khan
academy listeners you can join us
teachers have you checked it out are you
using khan academy with your students
how's it going is this the magic bullet
to get us back in the game on math and
science 800-423-8255
i'm tom ashbrook this is on point we're
talking this hour with salman khan
founder of khan academy academy and uh
one man kind of education sensation
these days his what now thousands of
online videos on math and chemistry and
now beyond napoleonic wars history you
name it as kids millions of them eating
up math and
chemistry and learning online is being
taken into classrooms as a supplement to
the teacher sometimes turning classrooms
upside down joins us today from palo
alto california you can join the
conversation is this a piece of the
answer to america's education challenge
and how will or should this
change the way we educate
800-423-8255 is our number
800-423 talk maxine in lancaster
kentucky you're on the air with solomon
khan
good morning hi
um
yeah
i'm sorry
hi maxine you're on what what do you
know
um yes um i am an elementary teacher
i had a tutoring service now that i
tutor kids that my heart goes out to
those who are falling between the
floor planks of the public schools
one of my very frustrations for when i
was doing my student teaching was
learning that it was all about the
paperwork which was back when
but um i see today uh such an
unnecessary change in how our
we as teachers are performing in the
classroom
and what really excited me about
listening to your program um or and the
khan economy academy
is how it touches so many different
elements that are frustrating to the
teachers in the classroom where there's
going to be more uh paperwork of
tracking kids rather than teaching kids
which
takes our time away from teaching and
knowing what our students are really
doing and so this
provides documenting of what they are
doing it also really addresses the fact
that every child is an individual
learner and they really need to learn at
their own pace their own maturity level
and how income is coming in so
in tutoring i i have a picture of when
i'm talking to the kids and their
parents and helping them understand how
important it is in the elementary level
that if they're sick one day and they
miss that learning
lesson in math that day how much it
affects the whole foundation of building
a house on math
yeah
miss miss one piece and you're in
trouble here you can go back and get it
do you think this will put you out of
business with your tutoring service
maxine no i would totally use it and and
the reason i don't think we're going to
lose our teachers because we still need
in our human humanity
is that um real person there to help the
students say
yes it is it's wonderful with and i have
not looked at your program but i know
that just to have the the
the awards and i love it that it is not
that you got the correct answer it's the
fact that you keep on persevering when i
was in college i had a science class it
was on ecology and it was one of the
questions and we were on the computer
and and the first time i did it i got
the answer wrong and it says try again
try again and the computer did because
the the teacher had programmed that into
it because it was like real daunting to
me because i'm not yeah
but then the next time you know i did it
again and i got it wrong and he says try
one more time for dear old mom and i it
just stuck with me my whole life going
yeah you just you just keep working at
something so that little bit to get you
over the maxine i appreciate your call
uh very much there i think we might
incorporate the dear old mom
one more time for zero mom you know
there have been so many people working
on this digital future uh for education
someone you know that my friend art
bardage with the naval learning in
cambridge massachusetts is doing great
work on this a big admirer of what
you're doing says your format's perfect
your timing is perfect uh but his
question to you and it's kind of
implicit you get a call there uh from
kentucky
or
you know not all schools have all this
technology in them in in big urban areas
in rural areas
uh not everybody's figured out how to
use technology in the classroom yet i
mean how do you envision the future of
technology in the classroom what what
does it look like what's your vision
yeah i don't know
it's a very legitimate point
i think what's happened this is since i
was a kid in in the 80s you know we we
had computer labs then and and uh even
then they were completely unutilized
because no one really knew what to do
with them we'd go in for like 20 minutes
and they'd say hey put a discounted and
okay you booted it now go back to math
class or something like that and so
what we think is now we are giving a a
a very tangible thing to do with the
technology and it's not technology for
technology's sake it's about technology
to enable humanity in the rest of the
curriculum and so uh what we think is is
that now this exists there's actually
now a reason to do it and it's actually
not not expensive when you compare it
with other things right now you can get
a uh a kind of a a handheld pc for 200
that can last four years that's that's
fifty dollars a year and uh and you
don't have to and it could be shared by
multiple students so it actually goes
down to you know only you know 10 or 20
dollars per student per year which is uh
uh super cost effective even compared to
textbooks or and especially you know the
eight to ten thousand dollars a year
that a lot of public school systems
might spend on per pupil well take it
from there though let's say i don't know
bill gates gives you you know 50 or 100
billion dollars you've got all the money
in the world to work on this and there's
the american education system let's say
you can get your technology in
everywhere what does the actual
education look like in a fully
technology empowered american education
system what's it look like
i think what you'll see in this you know
we want to see more and more of this is
the the school of the future is going to
be uh
kind of going to revert back to the the
one room schoolhouse where you have kids
of all ages at all different skill
levels they might not even be kids uh
even college students they're all in
that one room and they're all learning
at their own pace uh they it frees up
time for them to do things that are
actual expressions of their creativity
so actually uh writing computer programs
building robots composing music whatever
it is uh that that's there's time freed
up to do that and that they have mentors
and teachers that are constantly walking
around um
and and mentoring them in these projects
and and getting them past the hurdles
the way that that courtney's doing in in
her class and i want to point out i mean
this is the interesting thing is that
there's no reason why it's just the u.s
it's really a worldwide phenomenon here
we're actually right now translating the
content into 10 languages and
you know the idea is is that we also
want to eventually localize the software
so that a student anywhere can can start
to get a pretty good scaffold and as
important as the self-paced learning is
in in the us and it's super important
here it's even more important for a kid
in in india who
has to work half the day or or who had
you know who's
never learned to read or has been out of
school for for five or six years tech
powered self-paced
is that a
systemic change that could fix our
problems you've heard the news out today
you know the new act scores for college
admissions showing that just one in four
american graduates in the class of 2011
who took the exam met their four key
benchmarks i mean can you put
self-pacing and this kind of you know
series of
tech lectures technology in the
classroom and fix that or does it take
something else something more
it's an open question we'll we'll find
out the unfortunate thing is right now
based on things like act scores or some
of these state exams to graduate a lot
of students i mean if you just look at
the stats of how many students have to
take remedial math or college algebra uh
when they get to college if they even
get there it's it's it's a huge number i
mean it's it's it's a majority and and
you uh it makes you think well what what
has happened in there to to them over
the course of the last seven eight years
in high school and in middle school and
the answer isn't isn't it it's actually
not a problem with the teachers it's not
a problem with students it's exactly
what the teacher from kentucky was
pointing out is that if you miss one day
of school when in third grade or you
don't learn how to your multiplication
tables properly or you don't 100 percent
master negative numbers that's going to
be a gap in your foundation that's going
to last with you your lifetime at some
point that gap is going to allow
something to crumble and when you get to
algebra or calculus and we're seeing
that across the board and and so we hope
that that what we're doing here can
really address that and allow people to
go back and and make sure they have a
hundred percent foundation um so so that
they can stay on on a track wired
magazine says you never intended to
become an edu education revolutionary
are you an education revolutionary sonic
you know we don't want to um you know
the one thing we we shy away from is is
trying to make more of it than what it
is we hope it can be as much as as
possible but you know our focus on our
team we generally just want to keep
building stuff uh seeing how it works
looking at the data
getting feedback from users and making
it better and better and exploring where
it can be used and
and really avoid getting into kind of
the more more political debates about it
well i don't know if you're going to be
able to avoid that in the world of
education
you're making a pretty good whack at it
so far and it's been great to have you
with us today sami khan he's produced
more than 2 400 videos on topics from
math and chemistry to history you can
find a selection of those videos at our
website
onpointradio.org founder and executive
director of khan academy salman khan in
palo alto thank you very much for being
with us today great talking with you
thanks for having me tom in a moment a
free online class in the basics of
artificial intelligence this is on point
when stanford university announced a
free online class this fall in
artificial intelligence word got around
now more than 58 000 students from
around the globe have signed up to take
the class taught by two leading experts
from silicon valley students won't get
credit but they will be taught by two of
google's stars and leading ai experts
sebastian throne and stanford peter
norvig joining me now from mountain view
california is peter norvig director of
research at google who is stanford
research uh for who with stanford
stanford research professor sebastian
throne is teaching introduction of
artificial intelligence at stanford this
fall peter norvig welcome to one point
thanks very much for being with us hi
tom great to be here so what exactly is
the course going to cover what's the
range here is an introductory course in
ai
it's it's the introductory course in
artificial intelligence the standard
courses uh taught at stanford and it
does require prerequisites in
mathematics and programming so it's a
not an introductory course for anyone
but for somebody who has that kind of
background so how do you determine who
has the prerequisite background to
show up and and take it very remotely
your free online course uh well we've uh
offered it for anybody to sign up and
we've made clear what the syllabus is
what we're going to cover and try to
describe
uh what's required uh what what
background is required
and then it's up to the students to to
do their work and we we wanted to make
the course such that it's
as similar as we can make it to
a live course taught
on campus
there's lots of materials online
you know i've heard about sal i've
talked with sal before and uh he's one
of the inspirations for what we've done
but he has a approach where it's up to
the student to do their work or it's
supplemental to a course we wanted to
see can we provide the experience of a
real course online with homeworks due
every week and so the students will
quickly find out
can they do the homeworks or not
and we'll expect them to keep up so that
raises a couple of questions but the
first one is just this 58 000 and maybe
it's more than that by now but this
we're just about at 85 000. 85 000 did
you have any expectation when you
stepped up to do to offer this course
peter norvig that you would attract that
kind of audience uh no so uh but you
know sebastian and i thought about this
we thought uh we taught the course at
stanford before uh just for uh stanford
students and we said uh we want to open
it up we want to do this experiment to
see if we can reach more people in the
world and
sebastian said we could reach 10 000
people and and i thought he was
exaggerating but we'll definitely get a
couple thousand
uh we had no idea that we were going to
get this many now
so far we only have their uh email
addresses so that's not a lot of work to
ask out of them right when they start
having to do the actual homeworks uh we
expect some of them will drop interest
from 175 countries around the world 85
000 now signed up what do you make of
that how do you
how do you interpret that what seems
like enormous amount of interest in
people
as you say you'll see what happens but
so far willing to put their hand up and
say i want to study artificial
intelligence with you guys maybe
thousands of miles away at stanford
university
uh yes a tremendous response uh
i think it just shows that there's a lot
of interest out there that
people want to have access to this type
of material they want to learn they
think this is an interesting topic
interesting set of teachers maybe and
stanford's a well-known university
and bringing all those things together
and making them available for free in a
real course where you can be evaluated
uh it's just something that's a little
bit novel
lots of people have done similar types
approaches before but we put all the
pieces together in just a slightly
different way when you talk about a
small world here you're out presumably
as director of research at google former
nasa scientist you're on the cutting
edge of ai you're going to be
instructing people literally from
around the world i'm trying to take on
board
what this trend that you're part of
means about global understanding at the
cutting edge of high science does this
speed the creation of a real sort of
homogeneous global community of
scientific insight i hope so that's what
we're trying to do uh you know we're
trying to make it easier for more people
to get access to uh this type of
information so you don't have to get a
phd to study ai you can try it out in a
format that that's easier
and uh and see if it makes sense for you
and who is ai useful to do you have to
be an engineer and a high tech company
for this to be
useful or what's the range of profiles
of people for whom you think this might
be
valuable
uh
i guess to to apply all the techniques
uh it makes more sense to be in in some
type of uh of a company i think it's
it's broader than just the computer
industry so you're seeing applications
in
biology in finance uh sort of across the
board in
in any type of profession that's
dealing with interpreting data
interpreting uncertainty
these techniques are useful
and does google your director of
research there do they have any concern
that you're giving away the store to the
world
no so google's been extremely supportive
you know it's always been our mission to
provide access to information
and uh there's just one more way to do
it and uh they're behind it 100
okay we've got a lot of listeners right
now what's a or the key insight that you
hope people come away from a semester of
ai with is sort of is there some
fundamental orientation toward
artificial intelligence or fundamental
piece of understanding you hope people
get
i i guess uh to try to demystify it you
know so people have
visions of robots from science fiction
stories
without quite understanding how they got
there
so we want to
show that by
analyzing using mathematical techniques
using programming techniques that you
could understand what it is that a robot
can do or not do understand how to
interpret data in the world and make
sense of it and will computers
intelligence
outpace our own has it already when you
add it all up
i don't really think about it as
outpacing i think of it as augmenting
uh so there's already uh places where a
computer outpaces us
my computer is much better at uh
multiplying ten digit numbers than i am
and there's places where uh people are
better than computers and so i think of
how can we work together peter norvig
director of research at google guest
lecture at stanford university he'll be
teaching with sebastian throne a free
online course in artificial intelligence
this fall 85 000 people already signed
up for that from right around the world
peter norvig in mountain view california
thank you very much for being with us
today thank you listeners thanks for
joining us i'm tom ashbrook this is
onpoint
onpoint is a production of wbur boston
and npr